TIME THIS MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
RAFAEL, THANK YOU AS WELL FOR
BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
HERE WITH US NOW CONTRIBUTING
COLUMNIST FOR THE "WASHINGTON
POST" GEORGE CONWAY AND FORMER
NIXON WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL JOHN
DEAN.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
COUNSELOR, FOR A QUICK REACTION
ON WHAT WE HEARD THERE.
IT'S HEARSAY, HE WASN'T SAYING
THAT HE KNOWS ROGER STONE WAS IN
CONTACT WITH THE OATH KEEPERS IN
2016, BUT, AGAIN, IT'S ROGER
STONE AND THE OATH KEEPERS IN
THE SAME SENTENCE HERE, THE
OVERALL SIGNIFICANCE?
>> WELL, THE SIGNIFICANCE IS WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE LINKS
BETWEEN THE OATH KEEPERS AND
ROGER STONE.
I THINK HE WAS USING THEM FOR
SECURITY AT ONE POINT.
AND I THINK IT DOVE TAILS WITH A
COUPLE OPEN QUESTIONS THAT WERE
LEFT YESTERDAY.
ONE, WAS HOW DID SOME OF THE
STOP THE STEAL ORGANIZERS KNOW
THAT TRUMP WAS GOING TO
SPONTANEOUSLY URGE THEM TO MARCH
TO CAPITOL HILL.
THERE WAS SOME CONNECTION THERE
BETWEEN ALI ALEXANDER AND THE
WHITE HOUSE, WAS IT THROUGH
STONE?
WAS IT THROUGH GIULIANI?
WAS IT THROUGH BANNON?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS A LOT OF UNEXPLORED
TERRITORY THERE, THE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE WHO ENDED UP
GOING UP TO CAPITOL HILL OR
ORGANIZING THAT RALLY AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THIS GETS TO MY BASIC OVERALL
QUESTION WHICH IS LEGALLY
SPEAKING -- I KNOW THIS WASN'T A
LEGAL HEARING -- WHAT'S
DIFFERENT TODAY BASED ON WHAT WE
HEARD FROM YESTERDAY.
I WANT TO PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF
VICE CHAIR LIZ CHENEY HOW SHE
MADE HER ARGUMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
76-YEAR-OLD MAN, HE IS NOT AN
IMPRESSIONABLE CHILD.
NO RATIONAL OR SANE MAN IN HIS
POSITION COULD DISREGARD THAT
INFORMATION AND REACH THE
OPPOSITE CONCLUSION.
AND DONALD TRUMP CANNOT ESCAPE
RESPONSIBILITY BY BEING
WILLFULLY BLIND.
>> OKAY.
JOHN, WILLFULLY BLIND, CAREFULLY
CHOSEN WORDS.
WHY -- AND BEYOND THAT THE LEGAL
SIGNIFICANCE OR PROGRESS THAT
WAS MADE BY THE COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY.
>> WELL, FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW WHAT WILLFULLY BLIND S IT'S
JUST TURNING AWAY AND NOT
LOOKING WHEN YOU KNOW
MISBEHAVIOR IS OCCURRING.
IT WAS USED A LOT IN THE DRUG
CASES WHERE PEOPLE WOULD, SAY,
LAUNDER MONEY, THEY WOULD SAY I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT WAS DRUG MONEY,
BUT IT'S A WELL-REFINED CONCEPT
IN THE LAW AND IT CAN BE USED
VERY EFFECTIVELY.
THAT'S WHAT TRUMP MAY BE TRYING
TO DO, SO SHE'S PINNING RIGHT
RIGHT EARLY AND SAYING WE ARE
NOT GOING TO COAL RATE THIS.
>> JOHN, WHAT DID YOU THINK
ABOUT SOME OF THESE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS THAT GEORGE RAISES
FROM YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW DID
THEY -- ASSUMING MANY OF THEM
KNOWING THAT TRUMP WAS GOING TO
CALL FOR THEM TO GO TO THE
CAPITOL, EVEN THOUGH IT WASN'T
IN THE ACTUAL SPEECH, TRUMP WAS
AD-LIBBING IT EVEN THOUGH HE
PLANNED TO SAY IT, WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN TO YOU?
>> WELL, WE DID LEARN THAT HE
HAD TIPPED HIS HAND TO SEVERAL
PEOPLE.
SO THE WORD HAD PROBABLY GONE
OUT QUIETLY, THEY KNEW WHAT THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN THEY
GOT THERE.
THEY WERE LOADING THEIR ARMS AND
PUTTING THEM OVER IN VIRGINIA,
THEY WERE READY TO DO WHATEVER
WAS NECESSARY.
SO I THINK THERE WAS MORE -- THE
BREACH WAS HUGE, BUT NOT FOR ANY
WAY OTHER THAN TO HELP THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WHO WERE THERE TO
CAUSE TROUBLE.
>> GEORGE, THE FACT THAT THERE
IS EVIDENCE, IT SEEMS, THAT IT
WAS PLANNED AND THE FACT THERE
IS EVIDENCE IT SEEMS THAT IT WAS
ATTEMPTED TO BE KEPT QUIET, WHAT
DOES THE COMBINATION THERE MEAN?
>> THAT COMBINATION IS YOU'VE
GOT A CONSPIRACY BECAUSE THERE'S
POTENTIALLY A CONSPIRACY BECAUSE
YOU HAVE INFORMATION FLOW,
PEOPLE ARE TALKING TO ONE
ANOTHER AND NOT EVERY PERSON HAS
TO TALK TO EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
CONSPIRACY.
THE INFORMATION FLOW IS VERY
INTERESTING WITH THAT.
AND THE FACT THAT IT WAS
CONCEALED SHOWS THE POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL INTENT BECAUSE IT SHOWS
THAT YOU KNEW YOU WERE DOING
SOMETHING WRONG, SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD BE CALLED OUT ON, AND
SO YOU DIDN'T WANT IT TO BE
REVEALED UNTIL THE VERY MOMENT
YOU WANTED TO BRING IT OUT.
SO BOTH OF THOSE -- I MEAN,
THOSE ARE VERY INTERESTING
QUESTIONS RAISED BY THOSE FACTS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY FOR
US TO ANSWER ALL OF THOSE
QUESTIONS, TO DETERMINE DONALD
TRUMP'S CRIMINAL LIABILITY
BECAUSE THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS HE DID OTHER THINGS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE THE VAGUE
ELECTORAL CERTIFICATES, WE HAVE
THE ATTEMPT TO COMPROMISE -- TO
CORRUPTLY INFLUENCE THE VICE
PRESIDENT, WE HAVE -- WE HAVE
THE ATTEMPT TO CORRUPTLY
INFLUENCE STATE LEGISLATURES AND
IN PARTICULAR GEORGIA'S
SECRETARY OF STATE
RAFFENSPERGER.
WE HAVE ALL OF THAT.
THIS COULD ADD -- YOU KNOW, AT A
MINIMUM WHAT TRUMP DID ON
JANUARY 6th AND THE CALLOUT TO
THE -- TO HIS SUPPORTERS, TO BE
WILD ON DECEMBER 19th, THAT ADDS
TO THE IDEA THAT HE WAS READY TO
USE ANY MEANS NECESSARY TO STOP
THE COUNTING OF ELECTORAL VOTES
ON JANUARY 6th.
WHICH HE KNEW WAS THE LAST STEP
NECESSARY FOR THE ELECTION OF
JOE BIDEN.
AND HE SHOULD HAVE -- WHAT
HAPPENED WAS -- THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DONE AS CIPOLLONE SAID ON
DECEMBER 14th WHEN THOSE VOTES
WERE SIGNED -- THE ELECTORAL
VOTES WERE SIGNED AND SEALED AND
ULTIMATELY DELIVERED TO THE
CAPITOL.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE FACT THAT HE
WAS STILL -- HE KNEW HE HAD TO
STOP THEM FROM BEING COUNTED AND
THERE WAS NO LEGAL WAY TO DO
THAT.
HE WAS TOLD LEFT AND RIGHT THERE
IS NO LEGAL WAY TO STOP THIS SO
HE WAS RESORTING TO POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL MEANS TRYING TO PERSUADE
HIS VICE PRESIDENT ABOUT
VIOLATED DUTIES AND ENCOURAGING
A MOB.
>> HIS WEAPON WAS THE CROWD.
>> AND YET ARE WE IN A PLACE
WHERE ANY MORE OF WHAT WE HAVE
HEARD WOULD STOP DONALD TRUMP
FROM PURSUING ANOTHER RUN FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> NO.
NO.
IT'S ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING HIM TO
DO IT.
>> AND WHERE DUDS THAT LEAVE US?
>> THAT LEAVES US WITH TWO YEARS
OF POSSIBLE HELL.
HE'S GOING TO RUN AND UNLESS --
YOU KNOW, IF THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PEOPLE RUNNING AGAINST HIM, HE
MAY -- HE COULD GET THE
NOMINATION WITH 35 OR 40% OF THE
VOTE.
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT HE DID IN
2016 BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
RULES ARE SET UP AND BECAUSE A
FRACTURED FIELD.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE -- THIS
CAMPAIGN THAT HE WOULD RUN ISN'T
GOING TO BE THE KIND OF CAMPAIGN
THAT SENSIBLE POLITICAL ADVISERS
WOULD TELL HIM TO RUN WHICH
WOULD BE ABOUT GAS PRICES AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH, IT'S GOING TO
BE ABOUT HIM BECAUSE THIS IS
STIRRING HIM UP.
THIS IS -- HE'S GETTING CRAZIER
AND CRAZIER IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
TRUTH SOCIAL FEED.
THIS IS DRIVING HIM NUTS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THIS
HE